we've also got exclusive new details on
Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie is divorce
battle two years after their high
profile and multiple split could there
finally be a ceasefire we will always be
a family and we will get through this
time and and hopefully be a stronger
family our quote from a source
Angelina finally realized her behavior
backfired
she started to see a change and the kids
behavior because they missed their dad
Angie said she felt a lot of guilt
because the kids were very sad so now
she is trying a different tact et has
learned that once bitter exes recently
set up a secret meeting at Angelina's
house in LA to work out how much time
Brad gets been with Maddox PAC Shiloh
Sahara Knox and Vivian the agreement
when Brad's not on set of once upon a
time in Hollywood he gets at least four
hours a day with his children also Brett
is allowed to text the kids without
Angie monitoring the exchange I'm so
lucky that I have a job where I'm able
to bring my children to work you know I
just have to schedule things properly
and make sure I don't get overwhelmed
we're told the two quotes hope to
continue to work together for the kids
you
[Music]